tras día sin gas ni electricidad
eliudmila antonenco y su hijo Alexander
vuelven a tener acceso a estos servicios
en su casa de gerson tenemos gas tenemos
electricidad Ojalá tuviéramos agua
también para usar el baño adecuadamente
el 24 de noviembre una bomba
supuestamente rusa cayó sobre su casa
las ventanas saltaron por los aires y
una de las paredes colapsó ahora a pesar
de que la casa está en ruinas madre e
hijo siguen aquí porque no tienen otro
sitio donde ir
la ventana se llenó de luz todo se
iluminó luego hubo muchas explosiones
estábamos muy asustados Me alegro de que
Alexander siga aquí si hubiera caído
Entre 10 y 30 centímetros más hacia aquí
yo no estaría aquí pero tengo 82 años no
es para tanto
otros no tuvieron tanta suerte como
Lilia krishenko que perdió a sus dos
padres en ese mismo ataque
nunca había mucho polvo no podía ver
nada mi hijo y yo nos escondimos en el
baño hoy a mi padre gritar diciéndome
que llamar a una ambulancia porque mi
madre estaba herida pero no había
conexión
a pesar de que el gas y la electricidad
en los dos servicios más importantes de
cara al infierno se han restablecido los
ciudadanos de gerson no tienen acceso al
agua ni a otras redes como la de la
televisión además el presidente
bolodimircelenski ha advertido a los
ucranianos que todavía no están a salvo
sabemos que los terroristas están
planeando nuevos ataques lo sabemos con
certeza y mientras tengan misiles
desafortunadamente no se calmarán
una situación complicada de cara al
invierno cada vez más cerca y para el
que los ucranianos sumidos en la guerra
no están preparados